hey what's up everyone it's 2pm tuesday
pst which means it's time for the lobby
game spots weekly hangout where we talk
about video games here's always peter
brown peter standard time
is that the new acronym is that what pst
stands for est
ethan standard time there you go
that is not ethan that's aaron samson
with us
currently not on the east coast or ethan
uh
in time
pete what are you going up to what's uh
what's on your docket today uh today
waiting for games to come in uh what
i've been up to is i had my little 12
year old nephew in the office and uh
that kid is really rad and uh had a lot
of fun how'd the swear jar go
we we're allowed to say [ __ ] around him
the f word not so much but
wait there are there are loud swear
words around your nephew i base what i
say off my sister who's pretty strict
about what can and can't happen and
apparently that's that's cool to fly i
have like seven or eight nieces and
nephews now and i never remember not to
swear they're gonna have an extensive
vocabulary by the time they're like six
for the record anytime there's a kid in
the office there's a blanket warning for
everybody not to be their usual selves
right yeah because like all of us are
awful people truly yeah myself included
but uh aaron we brought you on because
you are the resident division expert of
the office a game that has undergone
many changes since march when it
released it's like almost totally
different now yeah um division just
released their survival dlc on their
public test server only on pc and only
on uplay for the moment that's how they
tested their 1.4 patch
that game's super interesting because
like survival fixes a lot of things that
the core game
got wrong in my opinion um although it
is standalone it's it's actually
something you do and then you come back
to the core game and get loot but like
the core game of the division was always
a game that everything in the game
screamed at you like this is a survival
game but nothing in the game
was survival right there was just all
this extra stuff you collected and it
gave you buffs against npcs or like
you had all this random clothing that
wasn't really all that interesting and
didn't have any stats like a normal rpg
would so in survival
you get dropped in clean with like none
of your gear
onto the core map it's the whole map
and your goal is to make it to the dark
zone and get extracted so you can play
with 24 other players against the
environment or you can play against 24
other players sure and this also like
comes on the heels of update 1.4 which
we brought you on uh to talk about on
the lobby as well a month or two ago
which that was like a lot of quality of
life improvements it made leveling up
your gear and your actual the loot
system more rewarding and useful in the
long run right and then
that survival got delayed because of
that they wanted to make sure that stuff
rolled out to make the game like
more playable before they released this
but this sounds like like you were
saying it sounds very much more like
because the main appeal for me and i
think pete mean you always talk about
this the division is kind of appealing
to me because of its world i really like
that like you know christmas time
post-apocalyptic post-apocalyptic
manhattan but the game never grabbed me
i've only played like two hours of it
total uh and every time something like
this comes out it makes me wanna and it
brings me back in potentially and this
kind of survival bent seems like the
thing that could pull me in so like you
played it on ptr right and it's
available only through uplay right now
yeah on their public test service what
did you think about it overall
um it's interesting also like i i came
off playing a bunch of king of the kill
before a lot of the triple a titles came
out so
i was i have like another good sort of
survivor shooter to compare it to for
king of the kill what is that h1z1
standalone
it you start in a like an eight
kilometer square zone you all end up and
you scavenge your way to the middle and
then kill each other right so
like one of the interesting things you
have to look at in a game on the pvp
version of survival is player density
and i think that's something they're
gonna have to mess with a little bit
because like in a survival game you want
people to
have to worry about the environment and
and have enough player encounters to be
scary but not so many that it's
pointless and you'll just die right away
right right and that player density per
area is really important
um you could also play this just with
other players again so you're not you
don't have to worry about that aspect of
it but it's interesting because i think
the loot was
the loot in the game was slightly better
um
and the npcs were slightly harder when
you were just playing against the
environment so they've balanced it both
ways although
in the overall game world you get more
points for playing against other players
um
so you're contending with things that
the core game should have had you always
contending with like
you know it's a virus ravaged city and
you were never you never had to worry
about in the first game you were just
like whatever like you were just immune
automatically sticking rusty nails in
your arms and like picking up guns and
licking them halfway through the game
like it just how did you play this
reminds me
of mad max in a lot of ways both in the
just the activities you've described but
also like the disconnect between like
wait how am i supposed to be able to
survive in this like
it's hard to imagine how you can
actually capture that so like could the
survival mode somehow be integrated into
the main game or do you think that
that's just like so impossible at this
stage to me it's a reimagining of the
core game in a weird way like i almost i
would love it if they would port this
into the core game itself but you might
get rid of the people who are just there
for the loot grind because you're adding
a lot of extra survival elements such as
viral infection hunger thirst
having to worry it's having to worry
about a lot more things than just i know
like you know again eric tate plays
these games the opposite of the way that
i do yeah min maxing and whatnot just he
goes for the most efficient run for the
most loot in any given session right so
survival is more about the experience of
the world you're in a blizzard you're
freezing to death and you're trying to
make it to a goal without dying
um and the everything is trying to kill
you including
you know including your own health your
own health bar at some point starts
taking a hit you can start freezing to
death you can starve and then not be
able to regenerate your health so
it's it's not like it's not like a new
genre or anything but i think it's kind
of what the division
it's what the original idea of the
division was that's what the world calls
for yeah i think
well that's why i was wondering like am
i writing assuming that like enemy
placement each time is procedural or is
that like set spots where enemies are
gonna come out cause you what you
described to me earlier sounds like
something that has an interesting risk
reward factor where i get dropped in by
the helicopter i think the helicopter
crashed at the beginning that justifies
why you're like fighting toward the
center um you're infected you're
battling cold i know gear has like the
cold rating or the warmth rating
whatever it is yeah and it sounds like
there'd be an interesting risk reward
like you mentioned earlier when we were
talking about this like you're in this
fire fight and like each minute that
passes during this firefight if you're
not killing these guys and moving on
you're gonna start to panic because if
you're like you might be doing well
against these guys but they're taking
too long so then the cold is just gonna
start eating at you but then you also
have to contend with thirst which
affects your vision vision i think
you're saying which that's gonna make
the firefights harder uh is there an
interesting kind of risk reward angle to
spending time in certain areas as
opposed to just you know rushing through
and risking the fact that you might not
have the good enough gear to fight the
harder npcs toward the center of the map
yeah i love how intentional all of your
decisions suddenly become in the game
like before you were just aimlessly
running through
like for no reason just running from
point a to point b
here you have to chart your route it's
like i know that there's fire here here
and here i know there's a safe house
there i've got enough thermal protection
to make it so that's set but halfway
through that i run into npcs it's what
you said
how cold am i how hungry am i like how
much health do i have in reserve
and then there's other cool things like
the shield in the game was always
useless but suddenly when you can't
regenerate your health because you're
starving having the shield ability
blocks a lot of the incoming damage
so it becomes a significant piece of
gear that was not significant previously
so this and because you have limited
resources and you have to craft all of
these things including your own
abilities
it just becomes a much more intentional
game and it takes a lot more planning
for you to get places it seems like it
kind of requires you to be much more
proactive pretty much every step of the
way rather than just kind of uh letting
things happen uh throughout your time in
this world and that's what interests me
because
at the same time it's really cool how
far the division has come at least like
from what you've said from what i've
read uh i saw this like long form story
somewhere recently about the behind the
scenes and how much work ubisoft has
continued to put into it but at the same
time it's also kind of indicative of the
problem a lot of people have now with
like early access games
uh or just games getting released and
then you know like the criticism that
they're not complete they're just
releasing them in completely and then
you know patching them afterward i don't
know where do you fall on this i mean
it sounds like you're enjoying the game
more now than you did like multitudes
more than you did in march right and uh
it sounds like something i would enjoy
more again i can't speak to it because i
haven't played it much but i don't know
where do you fall on the game
being like like really engaging and fun
to play now as opposed to march like i
don't know like does it feel like this
is what the division was supposed to be
this is the first time that i've enjoyed
dlc in the division to be honest like
underground
was basically just a loot factory for
for players which was cool like players
needed loot um incursion they should
have just called a room i thought that
was a really kind of half-assed attempt
like the first time you got into an
incursion and you're like oh i'm in the
room and this is where the whole thing
happens that's
kind of lame
so this is the first time they've
actually
tried to reimagine the game in an
interesting way
and it's probably safe that it's a
separate experience and that you come
back to the core world of the game
afterwards with loot depending on how
you did
but
i think for people who enjoyed the
single player portion of the game who
who hated the dark zone
and who were not into the loot grind
necessarily
this is the first
this is what i would consider the first
piece of new content for them but the
first new single player
expansion even though to be fair it's on
the same map but the blizzard makes it
feel
kind of new again and you said that you
yourself would recommend
people play this alone and not against
24 other players i would definitely
start with the pve section with the pvp
section people can still team up and i
think you'll run into the same problems
you do in the dark zone where you just
get stomped with no hope of
winning there's no real good balance in
this game
um that was one thing destiny did really
well out of the gate was make sure that
their pvp was balanced
regardless of how good you were outside
of their core like
some other core modes you have to
voluntarily go to
um but when the end game of the division
was a place that you just went and got
annihilated with no hope i think that's
why a lot of players left sure so you
have the choice here of going to
essentially what amounts to a dark zone
and not get annihilated by other players
which i think is a better experience for
the people who who hated the original
dark zone right yeah this i mean
it comes out kind of almost at a time
when i would be willing to jump back in
right away but you know you have like
dishonored two you have watchdogs two
you have i don't know final fantasy dead
rising four in the way i almost would
have preferred if they did delay it or
they already delayed it i almost would
have preferred them to release it like
mid-december or something that's just me
being selfish but
i've i've had the weirdest itch to play
this game ever since i played like two
hours of it back in march or april or
something and this is the same
discussion i have every time around this
game because it like intrigued me before
it released and then you know scott
reviewed it i think and you know he he
for like despite its error like its
flaws he really liked it and he enjoyed
the world and he said like the grind
like despite it being grinding it felt
really worth it you know in the end but
i don't know like now the fact that like
pete you were saying the world itself
seems like it's pulling you in more i
kind of this might be when i finally
jump back into it like you have co-op
partners if the gameplay can support it
man like that that's so much more
attractive to me than i think what i was
playing before yeah for sure and this is
the penultimate dlc the next one will be
the last stand or just last stand which
is you know appropriately enough the
final expansion and that was scheduled
to come out around this winter but is
now due out in early 2017.
so yeah aaron thanks so much that is the
division that is survival dlc that is
does not have an actual release date yet
but end of the year end of the year
sometime before you know like uh new
year's and it is also available now
through you play on pc uh for some
players and uh let us know what you
think will you finally get back into the
vision is this someone something that'll
keep you playing amid the other huge
fall releases leave your thoughts in the
comments below
aaron thanks so much for coming on
appreciate your expertise with the game
as always uh we're gonna get
somebody on right now
we're bringing in eric tayon
so you can kind of guess like what one
of three games we always bring them out
for dark souls destiny or
i don't want to spoil it because i know
it
one of those two three eric what's up
team crap all over everything i just
said yeah he was just talking [ __ ] about
eric behind his back anyway yeah no just
kidding
um it's bright in here all of a sudden
there we go
that door needs to be not auto locked uh
people listening the lights just like
blinded pete and i
uh eric's taking his time getting over
here yeah come on eric tay what's up i
went around it so i wouldn't cross this
wide shot also i think i appreciate it
but hit the uh lights you butt dialed
the lights switch out the lights the
light switch and i was like maybe this
will wake you guys up what have you been
playing
what are you saying wake us up
am i being monotone what have you been
playing lately and don't say overwatch
because i don't want to segue into this
segment yet
okay make something up if you haven't
played destiny or banner because iron
banner is there this week yeah how'd
that go did you get anything good out of
it or you just
no i think actually i didn't i only
played a few matches but anyone that's
curious or interested at all the rank 5
pulse rifle was really good the roll so
i would say it's worth at least doing
that and then you can stop okay you're
also done at blizzcon last weekend with
justin haywald correct uh you played
some of the necromancer the new
character well the revived
didn't even mean that one the revived
character class from diablo 2 that's in
diablo 3 now but you said like the
skills weren't fully fleshed out you
said you seen zeit yeah i mean like i
personally
never cared that much for the necro
myself which is why my excitement for
that class or hearing that that was the
class that was like or the thing we were
getting next in diablo was kind of like
ah
well fine i mean we kind of have the
witch doctor
i guess necro is cool and i know there's
people that want the necro fine but yeah
there was no ruins or anything to modify
the abilities on that class so it was
pretty basic he had six skills you can
use them
corpse explode is fun but everything
else is just like yeah it's fine like i
just wanted other announcements i guess
yeah jog my memory really quick why
would you want to explode a corpse if
he's dead already to do area of effect
damage ooh
nice one like i have
i have six characters level 70 in diablo
three and i'm actually going to jump
back in with the necromancer and i
played diablo 2 enough to know what he's
about just that always confused me the
phrasing of that you won't get to play
him until the second half of 2017. sweet
by that point are you serious yeah
that's what they were doing
now yeah exactly right they announced on
the panel so i you probably want to know
when he's coming out it's like early
2017. nah
second half a second you know like
soonish you know second probably 2017.
like right at the turn of e3 sweet uh
anyway
yeah i know but you can imagine so
blizzard also started a
behind-the-scenes overwatch kind of
documentary video the other day during
blizzcon during their keynote and all of
a sudden it cut out and i actually fell
for it and thought they were just
screwing up um but
sombra the new character for overwatch
was officially unveiled at blizzcon and
you got the chance to play her you and
joey were also doing a live stream
yesterday yesterday where you played her
uh in the ptr she is live in ptr servers
for overwatch you could just go play
that now if you own the game on pc and
then just set the uh what the servers to
ptr instead of like america's or
whatever whatever your region is uh yeah
so i just want to bring you on now that
you've played here you said you played a
few matches with her uh we watched i was
watching joey who was really good at
overwatch playing as her yesterday um
he's better than you just so you know um
we can 1v1 so our suspicion was that
sombra was going to be an attack
character a lot of people suspicioned
them that rings true can you tell me
what you think about her after playing
with her uh i think she's a lot of fun i
think that she is more than just an
assault character i think she is placed
into the assault category but she's kind
of that hybrid that you were kind of
requesting for you know when we talked
about this last week she does more than
just
kill people right essentially she has a
hack ability which is super useful for
multiple reasons you know you can hack
not only enemy opponents which will
leave them only with their primary like
left click firing ability or well
console would be like whatever your
trigger button is um and they're passive
so like you know kenji can still wall
run or wall hop and stuff like and
double jump but like he can't use his
like um dashing strike ability and so it
basically
um renders them
mostly useless right because they can't
get away they can't use their core
abilities and then it lets your
teammates mop them up and then on top of
that she can also hack health packs
which you know are very key obviously to
overwatch because you know you most
likely only have one or two healers so
you generally want to be able to use
health packs to heal sure yourself right
but she can deny the enemy the use of
health packs and on top of that by
hacking a health pack it makes that
health back come back sooner so then
your teammates get more health packs
essentially right
so
she's this hybrid class in a way that's
more mostly i feel like almost the most
unique character in the game because she
can play
in very different styles i guess you can
kind of play like that infiltrator
harassing slash just hack
um and just bring so much utility to
your team i guess she does she strikes
me as like tracer mixed with a healer in
a weird like indirect way through the
health packs mixed with
i don't even know like maybe like what
other character i don't know why it's
not coming to mind what the characters
like debuff uh like other zenyatta does
like discord but you're not really
gaining that utility necessary well i
guess what kind of does her sleeping
dart yeah people's abilities yeah i
guess you could relate it in that way
because hacking does do kind of like
negate abilities as well as her emp
which is her like ultimate ability which
is going to be very useful and
like going to be part of big combos or
denials because it's basically like okay
if lucio pops his ultimate and gives
everyone an overshield and she knows
that or sees that because you know the
audio cues and one night and she happens
to be near all those people as long as
they're within line of sight she can emp
which is her alt and then it'll negate
all of the shield and oh it's in line of
sight i thought it was proximity no so
it's not outside
more it's like dead eye and diva like if
it's there it's like a big aoe but like
if you're behind the wall you won't get
affected by it okay yeah she
it's always tough to tell completely how
she plays as a member of team when ptr
when it's like you know five v5 or like
five zombies on each team with like a
reinhardt or something i don't know um
but
it's always fun like with a new
character with on and everybody i was
watching like the youtube the uh reveal
trailer just like you know i was
watching the count i was reading the
comments on our live stream which went
to youtube and they were like people
were asking like how would this affect
that how would this affect that and uh
people were saying like well can um like
junkrat put his steel trap on her
teleporter and people are saying yeah he
can so like if he's smart enough and
knows what he's doing and knows sombra
he could do that um another thing like
apparently if she uses the
the hack the cancel hack on hanzo when
he has one of his unique arrows out
either the sonar or the spread it'll
lock him to that arrow he can't like
switch to the other one because like it
like cancels out or whatever yeah
because it locks you out from having the
ability to swap it's like the same with
like uh another example of that kind of
situation it's like lucio if you're in
like the speed trance version or
whatever you're stuck in that version
until the hack wears off so you can't
switch to heal or if you're healed you
can't switch to the speed version
yeah if you're fast enough at summer you
can also cancel junkrat's chain on
someone if you throw the whatever the
hack thing at someone else quickly you
can cancel his chain you're talking
about roadhog
what did i say you said junk right oh i
already said the junkrat yeah roadhog
sorry yes
but it's also like if you throw it early
enough it still comes out
like it doesn't stop like it's it's a
very weird and interesting i mean again
it's in ptr there are certain things
that she can hack in certain instances
that she can hack and like stop things
completely and then sometimes it like
doesn't you know what i mean like so
it's just it's like a
case-by-case situation it's kind of like
what we talked about yesterday when uh a
lot of people were asking questions of
like what you can and can't do like you
can stop a
mccree alt if he's mid-channel like
but i think apparently like the stuff
that's continuous
um it won't get stopped like i think
once winston's in his rage form you
can't hack him to like unrage him or
like if um
soldier's got his going on already like
it doesn't stop his either like it'll
just keep going from your time with her
do you see her being more effective as
like focusing on one area like kind of
being a skirmisher or a pest or focusing
just on the health pack hacks or
focusing just on you know actually
attacking do you think do you think she
would be useful as a jack of all trades
throughout each match or do you think
someone really needs to focus on one
thing
uh that's hard to say i mean she does
sorry she just seems like such a
complicated character like in terms of
what you're thinking about throughout
each match yeah i think it's gonna
definitely depend on the the game type i
feel like right like i feel like capture
point stuff is like you definitely want
to get you know health pack um
domination so to speak payload uh maybe
maybe not so much with the health packs
you know what i mean like it's still
important but it's not as important as
like capture the point
um and in terms of
being a pest i feel like that's kind of
what you want to be in a way you want to
try to get to the back line and get to
the healers you know and do as much
damage to the weaker people that you can
her passive basically makes it you know
like when i think uh enemy enemies are
below 50 you kind of see this like
infrared highlighting through like walls
yeah almost like pseudo widowmaker and
you want to pick those people off
because like her smg is pretty sh like
good like short range but it's not gonna
do like a lot of damage so it's not like
she's gonna be killing that many people
she's more like to finish people off or
like with her hack
that then allows your team to kill those
people because they don't have like
their escape abilities and whatnot so
it she's like a weird assault utility
like she is kind of like a jack of all
trades in a way i guess yeah because i
would say uh classifiers are like
assault support hybrid but again like
you could just be a pure assault like
tracer and kind of just darting in and
out if you wanted to her damage won't be
as good as tracers though sure
intermobility because like well because
people can also read where you're about
to teleport whereas tracer you know you
can go in any direction
but you can leave it behind you do have
a good amount of time to like relocate
back like 15 seconds later so
she's one of those characters that has
like a high skill ceiling but like she's
gonna be very dangerous i feel like in
the right hands and very important in
like even the new quick play which is
you can only have one of each class i
think she's gonna be important
especially in the current meadow of the
game
yeah she's definitely not if i was
playing quick play she's not a character
i'd jump in as right now and screw my
team over yeah i just stick to mccree or
my girl zarya as i always do yeah so
zarya is interesting too because if you
have like zarya's shield up you can't
actually hack
zarya but then if your shield is if it's
not up then she can hack you and you
can't use your abilities obviously so
in you know judging by that could if
zarya is shielding someone else does
that also prevent them from getting
hacked if the bubble is on that person
then that person can't get hacked it's
like reinhardt where if he has a shield
up you can't hack him in front of him
but if you invis or something or get
behind a reinhardt that you see he has
his shield up you can then hack him from
behind that's interesting because at the
end of that infiltration short video
they showed zarya come in as like the
bodyguard of that leader or whatever or
like they're i don't know what the whole
like implication was they're having
zarya go kill sombra or something or
just body guard yeah maybe bodyguard
regardless um yeah she seems like a
super interesting character especially
like i said i really like those hybrid
characters and that's what i was hoping
for and i think people assumed uh i do
like that
you know like
i like characters like even zarya kind
of you have a few different duties with
her when you're playing you can if
you're good enough and chilling people
enough you can use her for damage uh if
you're especially if you're up close and
then the graviton started for my
favorite alt i'm just going off in
tanzania talking about zarya now because
that's all good
um she's somewhat topical she was in the
trailer yeah yeah and uh like you said
she can cancel out the hack if she's
fast enough because those shields don't
last long but you just need to know when
to cast them it's true cool so obviously
no
when are we going to have her on i don't
think there's a specific date a lot of
people have been speculating that you
know like when when they did anna on ptr
she kind of came out like almost like a
week or two after
um a nice period of time if you kind of
just think a lot like chronologically in
terms of time is that season two is
gonna end soon i think season three um
if i remember right starts like
early december or like end of november
and there's like instead with uh this
season um
transferring from two to three they're
shortening the gap of how long it's
gonna be between seasons whereas like
one to two was apparently like three
weeks they're only going to have one
like a one week break this time so i
feel like
having her come out that week like
towards that like right when season two
ends and before season three starts is a
good time because it'll give players
enough time like oh i have a week to
learn how to use sombra or like play
sombra and that'll kind of give them
prep time for season three yeah
essentially but i don't know i i haven't
seen a specific like date um but
definitely this year from what it seems
like so sure uh pete i always kind of
like bring up overwatch to you i know
you haven't gotten really into it why
would you keep throwing it over the bus
uh no this character makes me want to
play overwatch yeah dude play it um
what about her like seems appealing or
just i mean all the characters are kind
of so correct me if i'm wrong but she
has an ability where you can throw an
object and use that to teleport to
wherever it goes yeah so basically she
has like a device that you can either
set behind right go forward then
relocate or you can even use it as a
mobility tool where like you can throw
it in front of you right and then like
relocate yeah so yeah that sounds rad
that alone sounds super interesting to
me yeah and you can do that while you're
invisible
yeah well one of the abilities well damn
yeah so any any worries about her being
op i know you mentioned there was a few
examples where perhaps
you know a specific character's
abilities would negate some of her um
her advantages but does it seem like
that across the board or is it really
just one or two exceptions i mean it's
really hard to say i think everyone when
they first see her and see her tool kit
like immediately go oh my god she's op
just because of like what she can do
right
but there's not even it's like a natural
reaction right like and i feel like yeah
it's kind of like a give and a take and
i feel like overwatch is the type of
game where it's very rock paper scissors
there's always like a hard counter right
like even yesterday when we were playing
on the ptr when somebody finally got
frustrated like i'm so sick of these
sombras they go winston and winston is
like such a hard counter because he's in
your face
and like unless you set up one of those
devices to relocate you're not getting
away from him and you're probably gonna
die because she doesn't have like that
much health she has 200 health but like
she can't fight him up close like
one-on-one you know what i mean does the
hacking take a little bit like you were
saying yeah it takes like a like a two
to three second channeling and i believe
if you get hit it stops you from
changing yeah people are also saying may
is a good counter for her too because of
a constant ice stream that won't let you
even start hacking
does the channeling of the hack or
whatever stop when you teleport
yes okay yeah it wouldn't that would be
some that's something crazy
gotcha so you need to pick and choose
when you actually start the hack or even
go for it yeah if you have a character
like as if i needed another reason to
hate playing against maze yeah man all
day i know maybe no you're good with me
that's why i want to get you off this
side right now um no just kidding so
cool that is sombra she's the new
character that we were suspecting for a
while with all the leaks and that
alternate reality thing they were doing
not augmented yeah is that what is arg
alternate reality game yeah i was
getting confused augmented very
different but yeah so that's sombra
she's on ptr servers on steam if you go
and play on pc right now you can really
not on steam sorry she's on ptr servers
through
blizzard.net and you can uh you can play
as her right now battle. oh my god you
got it yeah i love it battle you know
what i'm saying you can go play sombra
on ptr servers on battle.net battlenet
whatever you want to call it and uh
she's not on ps4 now we don't have any
word on when she'll be there but like
eric tay said probably right around
season three is getting ready
yeah i speculate cool though awesome
well eric tay i don't like please you
don't want to leave you're just going to
like jake get on there thanks so much
for coming on yeah you're welcome uh
bringing jake on talk mass effect
it's been a while in front of this camp
what is going on here you never know man
i'm sorry three on the bus tonight
you gotta
i'll get back in overwatch soon we can
play great and the division overwatch
yeah not the division though no
i just brought it to you this morning
you thought it'd be cool it sounds cool
but i don't want to play more of that i
don't it just says what he thinks you
want to hear offset are you just my yes
man now yeah just to get me to go away
from your desk you just tell me and
everything i want to hear because i
annoyed you so much
all right what do we even bring you on
for and i'm just kidding uh mass effect
andromeda new cinematic trailer you
launched yesterday november 7th or n7
day if you're one of those people or
working by ios people yeah i know you're
definitely one of those people
so you and jean-luc did a like trailer
breakdown what it's telling us about
andromeda um you know this game has been
delayed a bunch a lot of people have
left the studio we saw e3 things e3 this
kind of
a letdown of a trailer yeah it wasn't it
wasn't gameplay or just weird like some
of the audio wasn't even synced up with
character
the faces talking like it didn't seem
like it was synced are you talking about
the one the e3 not yesterday the e3 one
okay um yesterday it was pretty cool uh
it was writer's dad like apparently alec
writer i like writer yeah so he's in it
this time because the twins are the main
characters
so you can pick between male or female
like which is typical of mass effect uh
but then what's different in this is
that if you pick the male then the
female character is still going to be in
the game she's going to be sort of your
wingman wing woman okay
wing person wing person so i want to
talk today mainly about like with
trailer and then uh mack walters the
creative director at bioware was
answering a lot of questions on twitter
yesterday about how this game is going
to play between like the romances and
the overall like genre it's going to
fall into that's the one thing i want to
touch on first um if you haven't seen
the cinematic trailer again it's just
talking about how
about the andromeda initiative um
like the 600-year trip that they put
people into cryostasis for like a bunch
of different species to send to the
andromeda galaxy which is a close
neighbor to us and the grand scheme of
things but again it would take like 600
years to get there according to mass
effect lore based on the technology they
have but it also takes place between
mass effect 2 and 3. so that's bioware's
way of avoiding the consequences of the
ending of three so
by the time you arrive in the andromeda
galaxy and mass effect andromeda
the events of three have already taken
place it's long after three it's also
like so far away that probably wouldn't
matter um are the reapers universal are
they in each galaxy uh i'm getting two
i'm not i'm not entirely sure i'm sure
if i
had done some like heavier no i think i
could figure out but i don't think the
reapers are going to be in this game i
know there's some things in that trailer
that kind of look like reaper tech yeah
but i really don't think so i think
they're trying to move on and um
yeah i doubt it it'd be cool to see
reaper tech we i don't want them
figuring into the narrative too heavily
again because i feel like that has come
and gone and you pretty much have done
everything possible the reapers uh yeah
i feel like we've dealt with that let's
not let's not deal with that again yeah
so uh but okay so you were the one that
brought this up to me you said it's
gonna be more rpg-ish than
two and three because the first mass
effect felt much more like an rpg
uh with its abilities in its character
ranking but also just it didn't like two
and three leaned really heavily into the
cover shooting and uh kind of simplified
the rpg aspects um but this one mack
walters creative director and twitter
was saying this is going to be have more
rpg elements can you talk about that
yeah so i mean it's kind of been rumored
before that they were going to go back
to their roots with this um but it seems
like from what i've heard and what i've
seen it sounds like this is going to be
very heavy rpg and still kind of keep
that uh
intense action like third person cover
based shooting
and try to figure out more of a blend
between those two which i think is what
people want
they want that exploration they want
that customization the rpg elements of
leveling up but i think they still want
that
pretty solid third-person shooting uh
intact as well yeah in terms of like
building a relationship with your
characters they also said loyalty
missions are back from mass effect 2 was
that mass effect 2 you're building up
the loyalties for each of the characters
so then by the time the suicide mission
rolls around they have a higher chance
of survival from what i understand yeah
um i don't know how those a factor into
this obviously i'm not sure you would
either but um are you happy about that
did you like those in mass effect 2
yeah i thought the loyalty missions were
some of the best things about mass
effect uh just getting to know some of
those characters were great and it from
what we've seen it seems like there's
gonna be a cool cast of characters that
you'll be able to get to know and it'll
be nice
at least i think it'll be nice doing
some of these missions without the
threat of
galactic destruction over because i mean
like some of these missions were like
help me find my sister or something like
that which is cool but at the same time
it's like we're trying to save a galaxy
here yeah who cares about your sister
she's probably dead that's what i would
always think did you
sound callous but right no like you said
i i'm worried about like billions of
billions of people not
yeah and susan that is what i really
hope they find the balance of this game
at least in terms of story i hope they
kind of like figure out a way to like
basically not put a clock on this story
that's at least too
stringent sure if that makes sense um
because i do want it to like take time
and build and
explore characters and universes and
fun stuff that's always a difficult
balance to strike with open world games
i know with mafia 3
hanger 13 was saying they really wanted
to
make each of your missions feel urgent
so you're not going to stop and play
darts or go on a date like you wouldn't
grant the thought of five although in
grand theft auto 5 that storyline kind
of allows for that more you're not
trying to bring down a mob as a revenge
tale
at least in grand theft auto 5. yeah but
i mean
it's also might have been just hanger
13's reason for justifying not putting a
lot of
minor things in the game i don't know i
don't want to talk about mass effect or
mafia three too much but um p did you
play the mass effect
games at all like mike mike you should
know the answer to this question it's
always no right you don't like video
games no just kidding but
are you interested in andromeda past
just like the hype surrounding it uh you
know so mass effect 1 is a game that i
was super curious about that and i was
definitely ready to like jump into that
game circumstances didn't allow to it
allow for it and then two and three lost
that rpg bend a little bit so given that
it might be going back to what happened
in one i'm totally sold i feel kind of
fortunate that i'm not wrapped up in the
storyline because it seems like three
faced a lot of sort of like controversy
yeah i don't want that baggage so i'm
looking forward to playing andromeda
almost as someone who just is new to the
series i think that's part of the reason
why they positioned this story to start
kind of in between sure but um also i
think it was mack walters again who said
that you don't really need to have
played the other ones in order to get
into this story and appreciate it which
developers always say when they come out
with like a fourth game like all gears
of war four yeah and play the other ones
and yeah gear support four and its
defense did a good job of that like
giving you that prologue so to give you
like a hint of the cog wars or the
pendulum wars or whatever before you get
into it in the original trilogy but
yeah mass effect andromeda the whole
thing that strikes me is you're a
pathfinder that's what it's called now
that's like your group i guess you're
almost like a ranger kind of right like
in investigating the andromeda galaxy
and just it's kind of a sci-fi trope now
trying to find new places for humans to
inhabit but i assume that's what the
andromeda initiative is right yeah so
the andromeda initiative at least based
on the other trailer they released
there's four ships uh i said three in
the trailer breakdown there's actually
four each one kind of is
run by a different race presumably like
the four council races i won't get too
into that
um and each one is led by a pathfinder
and that pathfinder they say is like
someone who's good with combat good with
uh exploration and like you know uh is a
good guide and then a scientist so that
kind of hints that
there's gonna be combat there's gonna be
exploration and there's gonna be like
sort of uh
researching different materials you're
playing a character that would be fun to
play as in a video game yeah yeah
exactly works out or you could be like i
feel like you're gonna run into matt
damon or some of these planets he's been
there for a while
i hope so that could be two movies i'm
referencing but i'm not gonna say
because i just spoiled something um yeah
no i mean it strikes me as like i don't
know like interstellar kind of uh that
whole like the whole
distance from the milky way the whole
you know like the time it takes to
travel there i imagine that could lead
to some cool like storytelling moments
like
i like if we're going to relay
information back to the milky way
they're not going to get it for however
long you know like depending on because
the mass relays from the first trilogy
which allow like the travel between
stars or and you know star clusters and
solar systems don't go to the andromeda
galaxy and that's why they had to send
these ships that took 600 years to get
there in cryostasis you wake up
you know you're presumably still the
same age i don't know i've never been
frozen like that
no what does it feel like you were born
like 400 years ago you just
pop down now
yeah is that my what my personality
conveys yeah do i have like a wisdom
about me no
that's exactly what i'm going for and
i'm not hitting it nah really nah you
could definitely be a wizard pete just
because of my glasses no your beard and
your glasses [ __ ]
yeah uh but yeah anyway and then they
said like same thing with romances you
can romance aliens same-sex romances are
back you can kiss a bunch of people
which i guess is always fun mooches
people care a lot more about the
relationships
the romances in these games than i do is
this one of these kissing games yeah
it's a dating simulator where you have
to travel
every potential mate in the milky way is
gone so you have to go to andromeda
galaxy
and bone
exactly yep
whatever alien species you want if
you've got game
so yeah
you're skilled in science combat
probably biotics yeah love making
flirting
uh bring a sick pick-up line with you
andromeda galaxy it might come in handy
what would your pickup line i just sold
that game for bioware what my pickup
line be
we're pretty far from the sun but it
still feels pretty hot right now
come on
off the cuff that was bad
yeah but off the cuff man you're gonna
have to like have dude
i don't i didn't have 600 years to
prepare for it
before i play the game and then i'll
i'll use it on some asari that
is attracting me
sorry is uh arya right the blue ones
yeah the yeah with like snake technical
hair tentacle ponytails yeah i mean like
you're proving smelling yeah yeah
i'd better bring a pick-up line all
right this is
um
where did we lose tracks this
conversation
uh i don't know anything else like that
the trailer showed you i mean like
obviously it's on game style right now
you can go to watch this uh mass effect
andromeda cinematic trailer breakdown
that jake and jean-luc did but anything
that you guys pulled out of that that
you want to talk about in terms of what
it might tell us about andromeda that i
didn't ask you um some things actually
to be honest i think more information
came from that other trailer that they
showed the kind of like andromeda
initiative trailer uh they just showed
um they showed some weapons some
returning weapons some newer weapons
they showed sort of a or they hinted at
sort of a uh colonization aspect where
you'd be able to create like colonies i
don't know how in depth that is they
haven't talked about that at all but
that could be something fascinating and
it kind of makes sense right if you're
colonizing a new uh
a new planet or whatever you're going to
want to create
buildings structures things of that
nature sure
um two to four player co-op uh still not
sure how that's gonna work um like a
separate mode maybe like mass effect
three i would assume the multiplayer the
separate modes would be the safe bet i
at least i hope i think it's gonna be
sort of similar to
i guess maybe destiny where like most
you're well no because you can play
co-op through all missions on destiny
right but yeah i think there's going to
be like sort of a campaign but on your
map or whatever you can pick like okay
here's a here's a four-player co-op
mission that i can do so i think it'll
be similar to mass effect 3 but it'll be
more seamless once again speculation i
don't know yeah um but i think that
would be a cool way to do co-op for that
game cool yeah i'm excited for it um i
don't know the game's been delayed so
much and people have left bioware that
have worked on it i don't know what's
going on over there we did an interview
with uh
aaron flynn the studio director studio
manager back at e3 which is really
interesting uh you should go check that
out it's also on gamespot but yeah in
the meantime i guess we'll keep an eye
out for more coming from i don't know
they're going to be doing maybe another
trailer with a mass effect or drama
initiative yeah yeah so
they're supposed to give new initiative
information like they haven't said when
but it's going to be kind of often and
the gameplay reveal is at the video game
awards which i don't know the date on
that it's usually in december though
it's early december yeah early december
so not long until you see more of mass
effect
cool so yeah that is mass effect
andromeda the new cinematic trailer in
the andromeda initiative trailer which
uh jake and john luke detail extensively
in a video breakdown on gamespot so go
check that out let us know what you
think in the comments below
jake thanks for coming on is rob getting
on now yeah rob handler is coming on uh
he's probably gonna fire in here any
second uh like he usually does but yeah
thanks a lot i've been using sunny turns
a lot lately i'm gonna fire in here with
news
rob like your sticker shut up
did you vote or did you just wear that
sticker to feel good about yourself i
found a whole roll of these outside nice
i'm gonna give them away voter fraud
there's a bunch of there's a weird crowd
and a bunch of boots and i pulled a few
levers and then left and i had this
sticker now you did levers
no i didn't vote yet i'm just assuming
that's
are they not levers anymore
why is it digital it could be a bunch of
touch screens
no i'm actually asking i don't know it
depends on the polling station in the
state
connect the line
you have to do a crossword draw push the
arrow to draw a portrait 16 across is
five letters the republican
party candidate i might be on the the
local news
yeah like we're filming people leaving
you know this is like
walking out like behind the reporter or
did they interview you it just looked
like someone was just filming b-roll oh
but you know you flash one of those
waves
yeah it's gonna be sick
but it anyways despite the fact that you
are our in-house political correspondent
i did not bring you on to talk about the
election because everybody else is doing
that we're gonna talk about something
more important uh call of duty infinite
warfare i mean you both played
finished the campaign did you finish
campaigning i did we both finished the
campaign i played a lot of zombies i
played multiplayer both in the beta and
won the game released uh miguel
concepcion reviewed it for us gave an
eight out of ten um he's not here he's
uh he does a lot of freelance work for
us but he's not in the office today so i
brought you on to talk about it because
i think in the office i mean you're the
ones that play the most yeah campaign i
played it yeah it's a pretty fun
campaign had a great time with it yeah i
think we agree the campaign is the most
alluring let's jump into the campaign a
little bit because that's the one we're
going to talk about the most but uh
to touch on zombies i mean like the
black ops 3 the base game launched with
the noir one with jeff goldblum that's
pretty fun but i actually really like
the zombies zombies and spaceland very
80s themed uh you know like neon clothes
there's the like the typical jock with a
sports jacket on there's the geek with
his he's got a bicycle helmet on i don't
know if he's what he's doing with that
uh but then there's you know it's it's
you could bring down david hasselhoff
and fight with you the zombies has
always been like i was talking to brian
bright well we both went to infinity
ward recently to shoot the feature
videos and brian bright the lead
designer on zombies was saying like they
were pretty much given instructions
to like to like make it as different
from the base game as possible like as a
break from you know the frenetic
multiplayer or just like the serious
tone of the campaign narrative
wait the zombies for a while had its own
narrative like yeah i mean it wasn't as
like it was a super subtle narrative not
really ahead
exactly so i think yeah that was another
thing that got to like steer away from
which is cool yeah so this is infinity
ward's first time with zombies uh
because like obviously treyarch started
it but um then infinity ward modern
warfare 3 did survival i think then
ghosts did uh another mode i might be
mixing those up regardless this is
infinity wards first time with zombies i
had a lot of fun with it um
it's pretty sprawling but they're still
the same strategies like if you haven't
played it like you know zombies tear
down these window boards and you want to
let the first few tear them down so you
get extra money for rebuilding them and
then at the end of the round you want to
try to get a crawler like blow the legs
off a zombie so he gives you more time
if he's the last one to run around
indefinitely and buy whatever weapons
you need off the walls uh but yeah you
can bring down david hasselhoff if you
go to this omnibot over here i don't
know if it's going to show it in this
game play but
he the robot after you do a set amount
of challenges launches into space comes
back down with david hasselhoff and the
robot's face looks like kit from knight
rider because that's where david
hasselhoff is right in space just
apparently yeah i don't know where they
got him like on the moon or somewhere
else but he comes down he fights with
you for a while
yeah it's really fun i mean again it's
pretty much just the kitchen sink
approach like what crazy things can we
do you activate these this like i don't
even know tilt-a-whirl i forget what the
name of the generic name of the ride
would be but it like starts this tornado
that sucks zombies up you can activate
bumper cars you can do a dance floor
that's got like the zombies become
uh like they don't hurt you anymore
because they're busy dancing and then
the disco ball becomes lasers and kills
like that or you if you're on the dance
floor i like that um
so yeah no i mean the zombies again it's
fun it's it's one of my favorite ones i
like it a lot and then there's
multiplayer which
every call of duty that's kind of what i
personally judge call duties by i mean
until like this one but you know the
multiplayer is always it's a massive
player base they're always gonna make a
lot of money because a lot of people are
gonna play them it's yearly release of
three development studios and they've
always iterated on multiplayer i feel
like this is the least they've done um
because you play like specialists from
black ops 3 are like carried over here
in terms of in form of rigs which are
kind of these like character classes
themselves but they don't factor into
the overall picture as much as i would
have hoped
so what i
what i liked about the campaign so much
is that there was a really cool dynamic
and change of pace
like you know in one moment you're
starting a side mission you're sniping
outside of like asteroids next thing you
know you're inside the spaceship
sneaking on on board choosing whether
you want to go stealth or not but
i think what was really neat for me that
i loved was the zero g elements of the
campaign and it i feel like if the
multiplayer was going to you know pull
from the campaign i would have liked to
have seen a lot more of that type of
stuff like these stuff like a room
in the middle of the map where they
could kind of implement these like cool
changes of pace because that
was
i feel like such a
such a theme just the heart and soul of
this push to go to outer space let's
just go there and do that in all
um shapes and fashions like in the
multiplayer i feel like that was kind of
a missed opportunity yeah i mean they
kept showing these uh you know like a
big push for their art direction was to
try to combine modern naval uh
technology with nasa and that goes like
carries through the multiplayer maps
right there's the one map frontier which
is like the space station it sees like
varying elevations between these
corridors and everything but yeah like
you said they don't use the space
setting to the multiplayer's advantage
to make anything interesting it's just
call of duty combat like vanilla call of
duty combat it still feels really good
it's always going to feel good they i
think they mastered it like i don't even
know how many years ago um the movement
if i hadn't played titanfall 2 i would
say it feels good but titanfall 2 just
feels so incredibly great that call of
duty kind of feels lacking and they went
all in with they went all in with that
you know with wall running and here it
was like you could do it but like would
that be
like valuable in any way no i don't seem
like it i felt like when i wall run i
just get killed right away whereas
titanfall it speeds me up and i can drop
on people really fast but uh the rigs
don't they factor in when you have your
ultimate like the perks that you i know
you hate when i call it the ultimate
like was that you yeah because
then the poor abilities yeah we're so
easily swayed to take on new terms what
what should i what should i call it the
the ability you build up towards and
then you activate i don't know climax
what is the game calling what is this
climax on everyone at that control point
that
was the game conference yeah what is it
what does the game call that thing oh
jesus uh do you rig
cora bill no that's titanfall yeah dude
i haven't played multiplayer i wouldn't
know i mean i guess he's going to call
it the ultimate
when you activate your super power uh
each rig has two
so this again this is another layer on
top of the pick 10 system that black ops
2 introduced you do pick 10 for your lot
out your weapons your attachments your
lethal your regular or your tactical
grenades the riggs is another layer on
top of that where you get one of two
like ultimate abilities you activate
whether it's a weapon or this like
shield charge for certain characters but
then you also have three unique perks
one of which you connected at a time
so
so each rig so let's say you pick um
stalker you can activate the one like in
like stay off radar perk
but you can't use the other two unless
that's part of the pick 10 system but
they don't really factor in as much as i
would like they don't do enough to
actually vary the call of duty
multiplayer formula whereas black ops 3
introducing that movement the movement
was different enough from advanced
warfare advanced warfare was more shifty
kind of and then black ops 3 was going
for more titanfall kind of fluid
movement
um again this just feels like a very
small iteration on black ops 3 like
treyarch's multiplayer that they kind of
started working on last year and i know
these rigs are
kind of an effort from like infinity war
we're saying to kind of cater to this
crowd this shooter crowd that's in like
you know increasingly getting more used
to these classes like that stem from
like mobas now you know that you have
the term hero shooter and like even
titanfall's titans kind of do it too
their character like these classes are
getting more characterized and more
recognizable kind of like i don't know
you might seen like a fighting game just
knowing how to counter certain
characters or something i don't feel
like the multiplayer did enough
for me to really just like i'm probably
not gonna go back to it when i have
titanfall um and battlefield and
overwatch still with a new character and
everything um but
yeah i think we're both in agreement
this campaign
might be one of the better call of duty
campaigns in my opinion especially since
modern warfare but i even like this more
in modern warfare i think it takes more
risk than modern warfare did um
not just because of the story which i
actually liked but the structure of it
right the seamless structure like how
did you feel about this like taking off
from planets going to spaceships coming
back down doing a dog fight it's pretty
it's really engaging and all having
looked back to that on it it makes me
almost think like geez was the timeline
of this whole campaign like two days
yeah like i think you're just constantly
not seeing that loading screen or it's
just masked with like really cool you
know cinematic like shots of like your
jackal ship
jettisoning out into space
uh yeah like some of the highlights of
that
campaign were like again these these
moments of like a side mission an
optional side mission that you don't
have to do and you're just
sneaking in
and taking over a um spaceship from like
outside like you know huddling around
uh asteroids going upside down in zero g
like just
really unique stuff that i don't i
haven't seen in a game like this kind of
sci-fi zero g element like i don't know
if i've ever seen it done
well enough where it's like you know i
guess to a degree believable
um
but it's great and the characters were
great the writing was great like
uh
a lot of you know really great in-game
um character
characterizations of people and like
development in general of characters
like handling inside the actual gameplay
which is really neat yeah like you know
what you thought was like a battle
between two characters something happens
during the as you're shooting and then
that gets resolved and carry on carries
on into the cinematic in the next part
and so
i totally missed what you're talking
about yeah you mentioned the next day
and i went back and played oh yeah i
didn't see that it reminded me like
something like naughty dog would do
without charging exactly right yeah
yeah
stuff yeah
uh
really cool exploration
levels like the remember this one level
which was really cool i think it was on
the mercury one
um like the power kept turning off and
on
and it was just a really cool and neat
dynamic for a call of duty game you're
exploring and you have to continually
turn your flashlight on and off i don't
know it's again
for a call of duty game which is so much
as far as campaign goes like so on rails
this felt totally not that and that was
like a really refreshing thing to have
happen
yeah you mentioned the fact that i don't
know i felt i sat down and unlike most
call of duty games after playing for
about two hours i didn't feel like i
played like four missions i feel like i
just played this two-hour thing right
that existed as it on its own and a
little weird comparison to you and i
think it made sense though raised to
jake i said it it's like the birdman of
video games it's like they disguise
their cuts or loading screens in this
case when you do side missions they just
like warp you to the armory where you
pick your loadout and warp you to hang
around your jackal but you take off
yourself um were most games when you
would finish a dogfight in a jackal
which we could talk about the jackal the
dogfights too um
it would just end and cut to black and
go to the next mission or the cutscene
this like you actually have to land your
ship again and then you go into the like
the docking bay where you and your
partner salt uh her last name is salter
you like rotates and you like have this
conversation as your ships you're still
your cockpits your ships are getting
going down the hangar bay uh you get out
and then you walk back up to the bridge
as like
griff the armory guy is telling you oh
that blueprint you picked up will be
useful for the next mission uh and then
you like you go back up to the bridge
you see you see the newscast of like
what your ship was
yes
it seems like a little bit frustrating
it was like can you have the news
reporters stop ratting out all the plans
how the [ __ ] did you get this scoop like
five minutes after the sdf is gonna see
this
they didn't know it's like oh they found
top secret plans for this planet
destroying sphere that they made
but then you go back to the bridge and
you were saying like you go to the
center console and we said it might have
a mass effect right you pick you go up
to this star map and you get these side
missions it's either a jackal dogfight
mission which will improve your jackal
the starship you're using or the dog
fighter the fighter you're using for
dogfights or you will go to these like
infiltration missions which a lot of
times start in zero g
or start in your jackal when you have to
infiltrate this battleship and then you
go in and like you put a bomb in the
life support systems for the specific
room so then you activate it and you
watch the gravity go in the action go
away and you're gonna i don't want to
spoil this but there's
you know you put on disguises you just
do stealth and stealth feels good it
reminds me the metro games you played
those it's it's not realistic in terms
of like their sight lines and whether
they saw you or not it gives it's
it's enough to like let you have fun
with the stealth and actually like kind
of crouch around and feel a little
powerful you know being in the shadows
whatever you want to say right and it's
one of those moments too where it which
is neat uh it reminds me like a metal
gear game where it's like
you are controlling your own stealth
until you mess up and it's your option
if you'd like to you know go back to a
checkpoint or you just continue the rest
of that that mission now you know with
alarms sounded it might be a little more
difficult but that's how it is and
that's how it's going to be and that's
very unique
for me you know you think of like all
gillied up like you get spotted for the
most part i think it would reset right
like
yeah
at least yeah it was more like an early
metal gear solid where you don't have
much of a fighting chance right in terms
of just all-out combat
um yeah what did what did you think were
you touching the jackal a few times
what'd you think of that dog fighting
with uh the controls it's pretty good i
thought um you know like i'm
i'm a huge fan of like
sims and having that full like
one-to-one like rolling ability it's
there
on the d-pad but you're never it felt
more like a like a tank it's a movie or
a hovering tank which is fine like
i i enjoyed it you know a lot of
starcraft or sorry starcraft star fox
kind of
arena type stuff i gotcha where it's
like
depending on like like you're not like
flying like you know through space on
like a tangent or like a waypoint like
you're just kind of like you know
circling an area that's swarming
swarming yeah it's fun i i enjoyed it i
kind of got bored of them like i did all
the side missions at once more or less i
think only a couple are given to you as
you
you know finish the main campaign
storyline like you get it one or two
more but i did them all at once which
was kind of boring
it's yeah some some locations seem to be
repeated oh yeah definitely there's a
lot of asteroid fields and like space
stations yeah i do feel that the jackal
combat would not be as impressive if it
wasn't in a call of duty game just
because it's so novel for call of duty i
think i like it more for how it fits
into the overall
sequence of you know like again leaving
your ship getting into a jackal manually
taking off kind of manually using analog
stick to like use your boost but then
you see yourself flying out you get to
the dogfight do your dog fight the
controls will feel natural to you if you
play a lot of first person shooters
because you can just turn on a dime and
hover or just hover in place and just
shoot something there's a lock on you
still to be sort of aiming with the
lock-on it just keeps your reticle
around the guy you're like the only
thing you're really trying to do is just
avoid lock-ons yeah you're just hitting
your flares when that when it tells you
to yeah so it just gets a little
boring like you kind of see the same
thing
you're hitting these bigger sites
carriers in the same way like it gets a
little repetitive it's still a spectacle
like you're getting like you know you're
over earth you're over titan like that's
cool this game is gorgeous yeah
especially in those cut scenes that we
just saw a few of uh
honestly just there's a part where the
ship or your i think it's your jackal
it's not the retribution the carrier but
your jackal is coming up like the bottom
left of the screen very small there's a
big uh asteroid just like covering the
solar flare from the sun to your mercury
uh and it's just gorgeous how it
outlines the ship and everything that's
like one example but just throughout
this game the cutscenes especially and
again the cutscenes aren't the only time
you're hearing dialogue and you're
seeing the story play out there's a lot
of times like ethan the robot me and you
like love i think everybody's gonna love
ethan who plays the game yeah uh ethan
is nicknamed for what is his like it's
like a call sign like e3 n or something
but he's super he's super amicable and
like he makes these jokes i actually was
laughing at like uh someone said oh you
got quite the personality's like yeah i
have uh i have the brain of a farmer and
then something like are you [ __ ] me
he's like really completely yeah no
ma'am
he's he's basically tars from
interstellar but like
with a much more like endearing like
heart-filled like emotion like he just
you care about him yeah you're like a
brother to me
uh one thing i just remembered and i
haven't brought up until now was
i thought the uh as you like
go through armories and it seems like
you're getting intel which then
are affecting your suit
like those i kept hearing
that guy griff or whatever say oh we got
something new in the army go check out
the armory the armory was only there
just to customize a loadout like you're
not doing anything with your suit though
if you pre oh so if you press pause at
any point in the campaign on the right
side it'll show you all the perks you've
accumulated they'll they just they're
passive okay you don't activate them
they're not personal that's what was
frustrating you stack i got all of them
and it like fills up the whole screen
like like faster health regen more ammo
but i like i didn't a lot of these perks
i didn't even notice you yeah they're
not they weren't something that would
just be stand out but i think if you
went through the game and played the
last mission again without getting any
of them you might notice i think it
makes it like you're gonna want those if
you're playing that so that's the thing
there's that difficulty uh [ __ ] i should
i should look this up but i think it's
either there's two more difficulties
past just a veteran now which is always
like notoriously hard in call of duty
games because you're just this massive
glass cannon you're doing the normal
damage but you can take like one shot
before you're dead i think it's
specialist there's one where you play
through the game until you die and then
there's no check once you restart the
game so i would be interesting to that
would be interesting to play that and
have that risk reward of do i go on this
mission and get this perk that's gonna
help me out later on or do i just try to
get through and be super cautious or do
i throw my ps4 out the window or do i
just do i drop it and just say [ __ ] it
because i don't know like i think it
there's two difficulties i'm probably
mixing one up the other is just super
hard uh so i'm i don't think i'm gonna
go back and play those i play the
campaign i think i've got enough but
i was saying like did you feel like the
idea of like you being able to like
sorry goob shoo right just chimed in
yolo mode i'm not he's right that's what
it's called yeah yeah uh
i felt
that all the ex you know the kind of
free realm exploration type stuff i
wouldn't even call it exploration
actually but like going into your cab
cabin and being able to like you know
pull up your monitor and look at your
the bios of each character
a lot of that serves a cool purpose and
it's very unique to the game but i felt
like like toward the end like are you
really
checking these things again are you
checking the board to see
what one of these like
high commanding officers you killed that
are like kind of like you know
what you can call them like like
vips like kills priority targets kind of
some of it was like neat and then toward
the end i felt like it just got real
there's no meaning pointless there's no
people like to have your armory which is
something that you get to as you start a
mission
a lot of times it's like it'd be cool to
have that on the monitor i don't know i
felt like they they almost
they could have gone a little bit
further with like some of that like free
roaming stuff i would have liked to have
been able to like have more
customization maybe you could you know
you get all these perks maybe you can
like
choose which ones you want on of five
yeah i don't know so final question uh
you play call of duty pretty
consistently over the past
13 years since it started campaigning
the the stories yeah where does uh this
one fit like rank
i don't know uh
this this the campaign story is is
really great
i i don't know if i could rank it i'd
say it's just in like memory like it's
like one of my favorites as far as like
characters that you remember like well
after like
like ethan some of those characters even
like omar like saw like they have uh a
lot of
appeal and you really feel like you've
come to know them because of these
really great immersion
implementations of like constantly
interacting them you're playing the game
and you're it's like hold on you know
i'm not gonna go kill someone i'm gonna
wait and hear what this person has to
say that feels like a choice and that's
pretty neat to see these characters grow
over time
uh
i am definitely excited to see if they
continue this to be a trilogy or
whatever
i'd like to see where this goes for sure
like i wanna you know i wanna know what
happened um or happens after you know
the end of this game yeah i think it
would be safe to assume that it's gonna
be a trilogy i know that was their
intent with ghosts but then ghosts was
wasn't that poorly received at the time
like are you looking at metacritic it's
sitting around like eight something like
despite people's bad memories of it not
innovating much and of course that was
like infinity ward's first full game
after the departures that formed respawn
entertainment in like 2010 with vince
empower and jason west leaving uh but
this one definitely didn't leave a bad
taste in my mouth at all actually i
encourage people to go try this campaign
i know like it's called duty and there's
kind of negativity surrounding that
because the annual release and people
think it plays a safe campaign i
actually think they took really cool
risks with highly encourage people if
you're a fan of shooters definitely if
you just want like wanted to check out
go see how they do this campaign it's
pretty impressive
uh but yeah so our review is up on
gamespot miguel concepcion freelancer
did it give it an eight out of ten you
can go read the full thing and watch the
video on youtube or on gamespot let us
know what you think in the comments
below
rob i gotta boot you out for this last
segment thanks for coming on want to be
here
oh man um
can you talk about like
reviews you're working on now or no
uh i mean there are games coming out
soon right like dishonored and watch
dogs too yeah
you know
maybe it's one of those maybe it might
be jimmy
yo how's it going brought you on he's
our resident tech editor what's going on
right how are you guys doing it's going
um kind of lagging any more coffee but
we got big topic to talk about you
published the ps4 pro review that's
right was it last like late last week
monday yesterday okay maybe i just saw
it come through edits or something and
assumed it was going on friday uh cool
so you i want to talk about kind of like
the games that you tried on it and how
they look but also obviously like the
actual hardware about it pete i'm gonna
kind of lean on you because you know a
lot more about this than i do you two
would probably have more interesting
conversation than i would between jimmy
and i but uh overall impressions first
like i remember you i was reading a
review which is up on gamespot i can go
read that right now um you're saying
like if you have the extra cash laying
around you have the tv to support it
that's the key thing right it's not
gonna be crazy noticeable if you're just
playing on like a regular hd like 1080
tv right so i would say if you have a 4k
hdr tv and don't have a console and are
looking to buy one like playstation 4
pro is a must buy pretty much in my
opinion
um if you do have a ps4 i generally
would not upgrade
unless you have an hdr 4k tv and have
the extra cache lying around
so what is it like there's some things
that you and jake decker i believe went
to talk to mark cerny about how it's
able to run 4k because it there's like a
loophole that allows it to run them
it's like it's like a shortcut so
they're calling it uh so the playstation
4 pro it can do native 4k in some games
i believe
the last of us is doing a native 4k but
most games are going to be you know
using what they call checkerboard
rendering which is
a 4k rendering shortcut that looks
pretty close um not quite as good
um but is less graphically demanding
okay not i mean is it two like delving
into minutiae to talk about how it works
so basically spatially it takes up the
same resolution space as uh 3840 by
2160p but it has half the shaders and it
does it places the shaders in like a
checkerboard fashion okay and apparently
doing so is an effective shortcut okay
interesting um so what other aside from
like the hdr the 4k capabilities what uh
what are the any other draws to getting
this console aside from like just the
visual updates and whatnot
yeah so it depends on how developers
want to use extra processing power but
some games could
instead of like pushing a higher
resolution
and hdr they could bolster frame rates
for instance uh some games could you
know run at 60 whereas before they they
didn't um and some games like shadow of
mordor push uh
you know better graphical fidelity so um
it wasn't super noticeable when i tried
it on that game but i did notice like
you know extra wrinkles on faces and
things like that does it definitely feel
like it's fitting into the narrative of
like a mid-generation upgrade versus
like a new
console like
obviously it's not that big of a
difference so i mean that kind of
answers the question but like as someone
you know just using a console it's
better than the previous one like where
does it fall for you in terms of that
identity yeah i would say it's somewhere
in between a console traditional console
refresh and like a next generation
console it's somewhere in between there
well yeah yeah uh basically what i
noticed like from my tests so far and
granted there weren't too many games
that uh supported the previous ps4 pro
enhancements although more are coming i
think on the 10th when it actually
launches
um generally the thing that i noticed
was that but you get better
anti-aliasing especially at 4k although
you kind of notice it at 1080p as well
and
interestingly enough colors look
different uh on the ps4 pro in certain
hdr games and that's interesting because
the ps4 the base ps4 also supports hdr
um but with both uh consoles you know
running hdr i noticed that the cover the
colors were more vibrant on the pros
still yeah when we i was at the sony
reveal event in new york uh a couple
months ago and naughty dog was there
showing both uncharted 4 and the last of
us and when they showed uncharted 4 is
when drake was underwater and like a
reef and
it appeared to myself and uh someone
else who was it was like uh i don't
someone else was saying that it looked
like the older footage
was it was it looked worse than i
remember seeing it i just played
uncharted 4 in march and it looked much
worse when i saw on their tv and then
they pressed a button for this build it
was just a button to switch to the ps4
pro graphics colors look much more
vibrant but yeah i just again seeing
that old footage like i have to watch
our comparison videos like you worked on
a bunch of comparison videos right
that's what i want to talk about also um
in terms of uh like we can go back to
the hardware side if we want to but uh
in terms of the games you know you
mentioned shadow mordor titanfall 2 i
believe was like released with ps4 pro
support um
it didn't have the patch when i tested
it although i think it's getting it soon
okay interesting um maybe that's why it
took so long to download didn't it take
like
a while to download for you too
titanfall 2. don't remember man no never
mind i thought we had ranted about this
i don't know something but i do
i do believe that
i mean i wasn't there at the new york
event but i do believe that the last of
us and uncharted probably did look um
as accurate as it did and that's
basically what happens when you look at
something that's like marginally better
yeah um like when you look at the old
version it's like oh wow it actually
looked like that it's like try going
back and looking at like a 480p like tv
it's like wow i actually
like watched that for like several years
it looks pretty bad now sure um as far
as like development side goes is it up
to the developers whether they
work to institute the support like
sucker punch has it with second son but
that game came out
2013 same with shadow shadow moreover
2014 yeah like some of these games are
pretty old i guess or it's like a few
years old like how do they decide
whether to support the games well if you
look back at the conversation you have
with cerny right i mean he kind of
stated that like look our target for how
much extra work this is going to take is
like
point three percent of like the overall
he told me it was gonna take one program
or roughly three weeks right and so in
my mind and i then tell me what you
think too like that's probably just
because a lot of the times this is just
changing a setting in the the rendering
engine right like it's not really like
they're rebuilding the whole game in
like you know a really intricate way
it's kind of just like yeah we'll bump
up the antelia thing or we'll enable
we'll enable this and then we just have
to bug test it right
yeah i mean he made it he made it sound
like they were developing the ecosystem
to make it easy for developers to to
patch right um and yeah games will have
to be patched to support the pro
enhancements they won't work right out
of the box
and because you know they're giving game
developers the freedom to use the extra
processing power you know as they see
fit
it can be a bit confusing as to what
the games will you know get with the
update like i said like i mentioned some
games will have faster frame rates some
games will you know have higher
resolution resolution textures or you
know just basically better graphical
settings the same dilemma every
developer faces they when they release
their games on console you know people
say a console can't run this game at 30
or at 60 frames per second next game and
it's like right because the developer
wanted the game to look so good that
it's then taking up so much power it's
not yeah depending on the console it's
dependent on the developer yeah it's
confusing to me because it seems like an
easy win if it would take one program
with three weeks to just to work on this
patch
what do they want though do they want
the game to just look pretty or do they
want to turn faster like right at the
same time though it's like if you have
if you've released this game that's like
three four years old or whatever three
years old um is it worth it to you to go
back and send a programmer to you know
spend time like recoding it or whatever
repatching it
because that you know the game's like
sitting in bargain bins right now you
know is that a good use of your time
yeah it's kind of an interesting
question too right yeah i don't know i
mean like like again reading your review
you said like overall if you have a ps4
just i mean if you have the ps or the 4k
hdr tv to support it then go for it it
might be worth it especially if you
don't have a ps4 but uh i don't know
from what we know now
of i don't know how much this would be
speculation but from what we know this
scorpio um does it seem like the scorpio
might be a bigger improvement over the
xbox one than this is over the ps4 do we
not even know enough to say yeah on
paper from what we know which isn't that
much it seems like it also microsoft is
is jabbing
sony's saying it isn't like a true 4k
system whereas there's is because that's
just actually running like native 4k
right that's what they're asserting so
far from what i can tell okay so yeah
interesting there's one thing i want to
point out about second sun
which is interesting uh it supports hdr
and on the ps4 pro version
the colors look much more lifelike than
the base ps4
um and uh but it's not always perfect
either because like the black levels
look really black which is a nice aspect
of hdr but at the same time it looked
almost too dark in certain cases
like uh the character would walk in in
between like dimly light hallways and
like he'd almost disappear because he's
like just covered in shadows okay
interesting i mean
i could not tell you what that game
looks like or i i play that game i don't
even i'd have to really look at the
comparison video see what the
differences are because i haven't played
that in such a long time it's almost
like a remaster i guess at this point
been to me
um but yeah in general like i don't know
pete do you think you're going to get a
pro eventually yeah totally oh
do you have a 4k tv or uh well no but
the plan is like once i get that tv yes
i will get that and like we've me and my
girlfriend have been running the same tv
for years so the time has come and to
actually have a console come out that is
like going to support it like you
surprises i am to see that uh that's the
impetus for me to actually start
thinking about this i mean my end goal
is to yes get a tv and get this oh cool
yeah so jimmy your ps4 pro review is up
on gamespot.com if you're interested in
reading that go check that out we have a
video review for it too or cool video
review up on youtube and gamespot so let
us know what you think are you going to
get this do you have a ps4 do you want
to upgrade do you not even have ps4 and
just want this what do you think about
this compared to the scorpio let us know
in the comments below
jimmy thanks for coming on thanks for
having me your weekend plans
um hmm probably just hanging out with
the girlfriend cool yeah yeah nice pete
what about you video games yeah yeah
working on overwatch by the way i want
to play yes oh yeah have you tried her
yet i have not yeah yeah i'm uh i saw
joey and tay playing her on the live
stream she seems like a character i
would like i like i like mastering those
complicated characters zarya is my
favorite character i think she took me a
while to she seems really op to me yeah
from what i can do yeah when i'm playing
her she is no i'm just kidding
uh don't listen anything i'm saying
gotcha trying to get trying to get that
diamond from jason yeah the ranking
who's your main
right now zenyatta mm-hmm yeah you're
this you're azaria yeah zarya mccree
okay yeah two vastly different
characters yeah they're both very good
so both in the meta as they say you can
see
yeah you're uh pete you're well we're
doing extra live this weekend extra life
that's right yeah which i wanted to i
think yeah yeah cool friday yeah
actually uh for people watching if
people listening uh november 11th we're
starting our extra life coverage we have
72 hours between the australia office
the uk office and here in the us and san
francisco uh we're gonna be playing
straight through those i know jess
mcdonald australia is gonna be ending it
which she usually does but yeah friday
the first half of friday we're gonna be
here in the u.s and it's gonna go to uk
and then come back here for most of
saturday i think regardless go to extra
life search for gamespot and you can
donate now starting now our goal is ten
thousand we beat that handily last year
we're hoping to do the same thing this
year obviously like any help you can
give would be great tune in watch
uh yeah we'll be i think we'll all be on
it at some point just hanging out
playing games i think we're leaving open
audience suggestions if we want and
everything so
yeah should be pretty fun money for the
kids do you know anything you'll be
playing
uh definitely some nes classic stuff uh
i heard you talking about symphony of
the night yeah that's
yeah yeah we've
yeah we've got in the cvsi building we
have like a tv or we have a tv for each
of the sites or something uh
and it showed like first i think giant
bomb did like a playthrough of symphony
night for some reason lately and i see
it every morning when i walk in they get
coffee and i love that game i think i
just like need something like that
series or whatever oh right right yeah
yeah yeah okay cool so yeah i want to
play that but yeah anyway guys thanks
for coming on pete as always pete uh i
haven't asked you yet do you want to
host the show next week do i want to
host the show next week
i will not be here uh i don't think i
have much of a choice dude cool so pete
brown will be hosting next week i'll be
out of
town for a while uh get to talk more
about we're doing a really cool project
coming up uh we'll get to talk about
that more in the coming weeks but
everybody thanks so much for watching
we'll see you next week
you